j'ouvre notre second débat consacré au
mystère Jean-Jacques Goldman deux
décennies après la sortie de son dernier
disque il reste la personnalité préférée
des Français et il est de nouveau au
cœur de l'actu de cette rentrée avec un
livre une tournée hommage à ses chansons
et même un film consacré à son
demi-frère pierre figure de l'extrême
gauche des années 70 condamné puis à
quitté pour un double meurtre Goldman
star absente et pourtant
omniprésente on plonge dans ce paradoxe
avec Jonathan et priez
[Musique]
Fender Télécaster en bandoulière le
guitariste Michael Jones reprend chaque
soir dans l'héritage Goldman les plus
grands tubes de son acolyte de toujours
Jean-Jacques Goldman
[Musique]
43 dates cette année une tournée qui
cartonne partout en france sans surprise
Jean-Jacques Goldman reste l'éternel
personnalité préféré des Français en 40
ans de carrière il signe 300 chansons
Jean-Jacques Goldman c'est aussi 30
millions de disques vendus une icône de
la variété française c'est l'un des
meilleurs guitaristes qu'on est en
France et
ses chansons sont entraînantes de
chansons qui restent dans la tête et qui
et qu'on garde et qu'on chante
facilement avec ses enfants et
l'empreinte du compositeur est encore
bien présente dans les bacs des
disquaires généralistes comme chez
crocodisc à Paris Xavier nous fait
écouter l'un des tubes de Goldman
version 45 tours
3 45 tours indispensables de Goldman et
je propose qu'on s'écoute la fait un
bébé toute seule qu'à mon avis quand
même
on s'en sont marquante et incontournable
des années 80
[Musique]
dans ce disquaire historique du quartier
latin les albums de Jean-Jacques Goldman
sont des produits phares dans ce bac des
dizaines de références pour la plupart
des 33 tours devenus mythiques ce sont
des albums qu'on
va en boucle qui sont ceux qui partent
le mieux mais aussi
voilà par exemple celui-ci qui avait été
un succès commercial déjà à l'époque
Jean-Jacques Goldman a beau ne pas avoir
sorti d'album depuis 22 ans ces
références comme en passant ou des
singles comme je te donne sont une
intarissable rente pour les disquaires
comme crocodisc qui en est cool chaque
année quelques centaines ouais disons
qu'aujourd'hui
quand on a un rayon de musique
francophone en vinyle c'est évident que
Goldman fait partie des on va dire des
dix artistes à avoir en bac une Goldman
Mania qui semble ne jamais se tarir la
personnalité du chanteur or aussi
discret engagée continue aujourd'hui de
fasciner plusieurs hebdomadaires comme
le point où l'Obs lui ont récemment
consacré des dossiers et l'historien
yvanja blonka lui consacre même un
ouvrage le guitariste est une star
paradoxale un symbole des années
Mitterrand d'une France pluriel et
sereine retirée de la vie publique
Jean-Jacques Goldman vit aujourd'hui à
Londres à 71 ans sa dernière apparition
publique est une vidéo YouTube pendant
la crise du covid le chanteur il reprend
il changeait la vie et rend hommage aux
soignants impliqués dans la lutte contre
le virus
[Musique]
confiné le mystère Goldman pour en
parler yvanjablonca bonsoir bienvenue
aux accueillir historiens écrivain
auteur de ce livre Goldman aux éditions
du Seuil Bigot bonsoir et bienvenue
président de TV5 Monde et journaliste
Véronique Mortagne bonsoir et bienvenue
vous êtes journaliste vous aussi
critique musicale auteur avec Bernard
Lavilliers de ce carnet de voyage écrit
sur place qui est apparaître dans
quelques semaines au mois de novembre
aux éditions de l'équateur Mathieu
croissanto était resté évidemment à mes
côtés comment vous expliquer je vais
commencer là-dessus c'est la question la
plus évidente ils venge à Blanca la
longévité de Goldman je pourrais parler
de sa musique d'abord pourquoi sa
musique traversent les époques alors il
est l'auteur de plusieurs tubes
intemporels on le voit avec les chiffres
des plateformes de streaming ces tubes
se retrouvent aussi bien dans les
playlists de mariage que aux obsèques et
ça ça montre à quel point ces musiques
ces tubes sont entrés profondément dans
l'intimité des gens d'une certaine
manière il y a une chanson de Goldman
pour chaque moment de la vie de
adolescence aux ruptures amoureuses en
passant par l'amitié et là et la
parentalité et je crois qu'il a réussi à
toucher au plus au plus profond de de la
vie des gens c'est ce qui explique sur
le plan musical ça popularité un des
modables Yves Bigot si on fait un peu de
communication là ça discrétion à une
aire de surexposition permanente de
réseaux sociaux même on peut dire de
folie surexposition permanente c'est
peut-être aussi une des clés de ça de
s'allongevité de sa popularité alors
c'est pas la seule mais sans d'études
effectivement puisque aujourd'hui le
meilleur moyen de ne pas se faire taper
dessus c'est de ne rien dire et de ne
pas exister donc ça effectivement de
manière stratégique oui c'est c'est très
très mal mais pour un chanteur on va y
venir évidemment longuement dans ce
débat parce qu'on est une mission
politique donc on va pas mal parler de
politique à sortir qui est engagé qu'il
est encore et qu'il l'a beaucoup pété
est-ce que c'est un peu
une forme de de l'acheter ou de retrait
de moins s'engager aujourd'hui non je
pense pas parce que d'abord son
engagement en tous les cas humanitaires
ou dans le goldmanisme que
un théorisé dans son ouvrage mais ça
reste puisque les chansons continuent
d'être elle parle pour lui voilà d'être
diffusée après son engagement il faut
bien voir que c'est un engagement
humanitaire c'est-à-dire c'est typique
des années 80 c'est pas de l'engagement
politique à la manière vous y reviendrez
de son demi-frère Goldman qui lui était
en révolutionnaire c'est Jean-Jacques
c'est l'histoire des deux gauches aussi
exactement et d'ailleurs Jean-Jacques
lui était pour la deuxième gauche grand
admirateur de Michel Rocard donc ce que
les communistes appelaient les sociotes
traîtres donc on voit bien la différence
et alors et je pense que cette
différence elle est d'autant plus
marquée évidemment que c'est en
référence avec ce qui arrivait au grand
demi-frère évidemment et ça on y
consacrera le dernier chapitre de ce
débat tous les artistes se construisent
d'une légende avec mortelle et
Jean-Jacques Goldman aussi c'est quoi sa
légende selon vous alors je ne sais pas
moi je vois en Jean-Jacques Goldman
quelqu'un qui sait faire des tubes et ça
c'est une qualité quand on veut être
chanteur populaire musicien populaire
avoir ce don finalement de fabriquer un
tube quelque chose qui marche et qui
continue et qui perdure et qui perdurent
grâce aux balles parce que quand on va
dans un bal du 14 juillet vraiment c'est
du Goldman on entend du Goldman donc ça
c'est la vertu du chanteur populaire de
savoir faire des refrains je me souviens
que Paul mistraqui qui était un ancien
qui avait écrit tout va très bien Madame
la marquise qui me racontait que le plus
grand plaisir qu'il avait eu dans la vie
c'est que avec les royalties à ce
moment-là il s'était acheté une voiture
et qu'il était dans Paris puis d'un seul
coup il y a un ouvrier parisien qui
arrive avec la musette et tout à
l'époque c'était avant la guerre et qui
siffle tout va très bien Madame la et là
il dit j'ai réussi c'est c'est le but
vous voyez d'un chanteur après quand on
est poète et quand on est un vrai
artiste on va dire on va créer
effectivement une légende alors pour moi
Goldman est pas forcément le plus grand
poète et le plus grand artiste musicien
qu'on ait eu en France et qu'on a
jusqu'à maintenant et les enquêtes de
popularité si vous voulez de du français
le mieux aimer etc pour moi ne compte
pas beaucoup donc si vous voulez le le
tout ça l'alchimie fait que
effectivement on doit s'inventer de
toute façon quand on est artiste on doit
s'inventer une vie on doit construire
son roman
[Musique]
précisément est-ce que c'est pas cette
forme de discrétion qui est comprise par
certains Français comme une forme
d'humilité comme une forme de peut-être
de rapport à l'argent personne connaît
le train de vie Jean-Jacques Goldman je
fais pas de souci pour lui mais de ne
pas être dans l'exhibition pas dans le
chauffe bon c'est pas ça
qu'il a écrit pour d'autres notamment
Céline Dion au niveau financier ça va
bien pour lui il mange à Blanca on est
personne
est-ce que c'est aussi un businessmanka
je voudrais ajouter à ce qui a été dit
que pour répondre à ma question quand
même bien sûr je peux répondre tout de
suite il est à la tête d'une petite
entreprise Goldman entre guillemets qui
consiste à gérer les énormes royalties
que lui rapporte ses tubes bon moi j'ai
rien d'autre à dire et puis après tout
tant mieux il a bien travaillé et c'est
ce qui mérite et j'ai rien d'autre alors
sur ce que nous disait véroniquement
alors en revanche qui est important
c'est que le fait qu'il soit à la
personnalité préférée des français
depuis officiellement 12 ans et
officiellement officieusement 20 ans je
pense que c'est très intéressant et en
tout cas passionnant pour l'historien
que je suis parce que ça renvoie au delà
de son talent musical à des qualités
morales que tout le monde lui
reconnaisse que j'ai appelé moi-même une
morale Goldman qu'on peut décliner à
travers des termes comme la droiture
l'humilité la discrétion la fidélité à
son histoire le fait que Goldman s'est
très bien il vient et je crois que ça
c'est assez unique et en tout cas c'est
différent des autres hyperstars de son
calibre on trouve pas ça chez Renault on
trouve passage chez Johnny par exemple
et la troisième le l'autre chose que
j'ajouterai à part son talent musical et
ses qualités morales c'est aussi le fait
qu'il incarne maintenant une forme de de
fédéralisme
parce que il promut une philosophie du
vivre-ensemble et je pense que ça manque
à beaucoup de Français et c'est ça aussi
qu'on retrouve chez Goldman le tout
dernier celui publié en décembre 2022 ce
qui fait de Jean-Jacques Goldman encore
cette année la personnalité préférée des
français il est devant Thomas Pesquet
Omar Sy ça fait effectivement 12 ans
qu'il garde cette première place seul le
commandant Cousteau
20 fois et l'abbé Pierre 16 fois font
mieux
je voyais réagir sur le le combo entre
les valeurs et le talent Véronique
Mortagne c'est pas le seul pourquoi lui
est aussi populaire
je sais pas il est populaire oui il est
populaire mais moi je n'accorde pas
énormément de crédit si vous voulez ce
sondage là ça veut pas dire grand chose
non je sais pas je voudrais bien voir
comment sont posés les questions etc et
je veux dire qu'il est populaire sur un
certain segment il est pas du tout sur
un autre alors le problème je pense que
sur tous les segments sauf sur les
jeunes voilà
pas que sur les jeunes mais si on prend
si on prend par catégorie d'âge en tout
cas voilà sans doute ce que je veux dire
c'est que on cherche tout le temps
dans des vedettes de variétés de musique
à trouver une incarnation de la France
si c'était possible mais moi je pense
que ça n'est pas possible déjà
premièrement mais que il y a
effectivement une volonté politique de
trouver ce roman national on le voit
dans le dans la discussion qui avait
entre Sardou et et Juliette Armanet il y
a qu'est-ce qui incarne la France
qu'est-ce que c'est que possiblement un
chanteur de variété qui incarnerait une
France un roman français etc Goldman
c'est super parce que il est tellement
caméléon d'une certaine manière que
effectivement il peut incarner une
France illusoire qui à mon avis n'existe
pas n'existe plus peut-être vous
n'existe pas elle a jamais tellement
existé cette France cette France
humanitaire justement très très enfin je
veux dire il est pas il est engagé mais
comme le disait Yves à l'instant il est
engagé mais c'est pas le sens que je
donne moi un chanteur engagé il est
engagé dans une politique humanitaire
sans aucun doute et c'est très vertueux
je disais une France du passé parce que
on va regarder tiens quelques une de
journaux de quotidien et de et de
magazines qui font suite notamment à la
parution de votre livre le mid Goldman
pour l'Obs avec les bonnes feuilles du
livre on a aussi la Une de libéral alors
là c'est le point je vais y revenir mais
il y a libération quand la musique
questionne je sais pas si on l'a vu
peut-être voilà la libération je vois
bien qu'on remette le point si c'est
possible quand la France les années
Goldman et c'est pour ça que je je
reviens à ce que vous disiez illigot
votre avis là-dessus est-ce que c'est
une France nostalgique finalement qui
place Goldman à la tête de ce de ce
classement des personnalités années
après année oui nécessairement parce que
ça renvoie aux années 70 aux années aux
années 80 ce que Patrick Sébastien
appelé les années bonheur
des années de quasi plein d'emplois et
effectivement d'une société française
qui est encore relativement
uni même s'il y a des tiraillements
surtout à l'extrême gauche mais c'est
une société qui est encore unitaire
héritée des années 60
nécessairement plus fracturé
qu'aujourd'hui on n'a jamais reconnu en
tous les cas de notre vivant et mais moi
j'ai ma lecture donc du Goldman divan
Jablonka moi j'ai vu ça
entre autres choses comme justement un
requiem pour cette France là voilà un
requiem aussi pour cette deuxième gauche
ou pour cette gauche sur tous les cas
qui n'existent plus alors Mathieu
ouvrier
ces années 80 on vit aujourd'hui dans
une forme nostalgique parce qu'on
préfère toujours les périodes d'or il
faut reconnaître à Jean-Jacques Goldman
peut-être pas un talent de poète mais un
sacré talent pour raconter des tranches
de vie tranche de vie qui raconte une
époque les années 80 c'est les années du
chômage de masse faut quand même le
rappeler c'est l'explosion que vous vous
souvenez la sidérurgie on a dépassé le
million de Mitch chômeurs on encaisse
les années
c'est les années du racisme qui provoque
justement la naissance de SOS racis qui
a un des rares engagements publics de de
Jean-Jacques Goldman qui sera au concert
fondateur et puis il en fera un autre
mais j'ai assez les années d'eratonates
c'est l'année c'est les années de la
montée du Front national c'est c'est je
vois pas ce tableau
idyllique je vois pas non c'est pas
qu'aujourd'hui
à part sur la question du chômage
beaucoup moins qu'aujourd'hui parce que
si vous prenez à l'inverse la question
de la montée de l'extrême droite et il y
a des députés à l'Assemblée nationale
pour la première fois en 1986 et
ils étaient moins nombreux il y en avait
quand même enfin j'ai assez c'est là où
ce phénomène apparaît prend une ampleur
c'est pour ça que je mais non
la différence c'est que c'était des
années où l'espoir existait c'est ça la
grande différence c'est qu'on pensait
dans ces ananas je vous rappelle que
c'est aussi les années de l'arrivée de
la gauche au pouvoir les années 80
pardon c'est les années on l'accue et
les années où on l'accuse d'avoir failli
ces engagements et ses idéaux en
arrivant au pouvoir aussi deux ans après
très pour être précis mais c'est des
années où on pense que les grosses vont
aller mieux Véronique mortel on pense
que les choses vont aller
si vous prenez les années 80 aussi c'est
le surgissement des musiques du monde de
la sono mondiale avec
ce sont les réta bits le rock français
le enfin je veux dire il y a une
effervescence incroyable et qui n'est
pas du tout goldmanienne qui est
complètement différente et qui est dans
une autre bande si vous voulez et puis
après moi je pense que il y a
effectivement des points de rupture
comme Ben l'émission il y a les missions
d'Yves montant vive la crise qui était
quand même extrêmement marquante sur et
finalement qui allait dans le sens de ce
que défendait Goldman c'est-à-dire on
s'en sort tout seul aussi hein
c'est-à-dire que là on est plus dans le
collectif on est plus dans la bagarre
alors syndicale etc on crée les
conditions de sa survie d'une certaine
manière et comme le disent avec
espérance qui n'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui sur l'engagement politique
on va on va vous avez commencé à évoquer
la question de la montée du Front
national dans ces années 80 on va
écouter une chanson de Jean-Jacques
Goldman heureusement que dans un débat
comme celui-là on écoute aussi un peu de
Goldman c'est là-bas quelques notes un
refrain de là-bas
[Musique]
tout est neuf et tout est sauvage
libre continent sans grille
[Musique]
et sinon rêves sont étroits
il faut rappeler à quel moment dans quel
contexte est-ce que peut-être que
raconte cette chanson rapidement et
pourquoi finalement c'est une chanson
politique ça ça fait partie des chansons
du départ de l'exil comme l'éternel dans
la Genèse commandait à Abraham de
quitter la maison de son père et de
partir et bien d'une certaine manière
Jean-Jacques Goldman a exploré cette
condition de l'exilé de l'immigré on
sait très bien que c'est l'histoire de
son de son propre père donc là-bas ou
aussi on ira ou puisque tu parles ce
sont des chansons de l'arrachement et de
l'espoir d'une vie meilleure là-bas et
c'est un départ un transitif en quelque
sorte et est-ce que dans une France
qu'effectivement voit le Front national
gagné des points ou le racisme peut-être
se débride après avoir été mis au
sommeil pendant peu de temps mais
pendant quelques décennies est-ce que
cette chanson pour vous elle a un sens
politique oui je crois et plus
généralement parce que c'est le regard
enfin c'est c'est on dirait migrant
aujourd'hui mais c'est un voilà un
réfugié qui raconte son nid son histoire
avec avec empathie avec empathie pour
tous ceux qui ont cette histoire
familiale de l'exil ou de la diaspora et
quant aux années 80 il faut vraiment
être amnésique pour croire que c'était
des une décennie de bonheur au contraire
c'est une décennie où il y a eu beaucoup
de cas sociales un chômage de masse qui
monte et Jean-Jacques Goldman et
quelqu'un qui au contraire a toujours
manifester une solidarité vis-à-vis des
perdants des humbles des petits il faut
se rappeler que il vient d'une famille
de petits commerçants et le fait même
qu'il ait participé à l'aventure des
Restos du Coeur ça montre bien qu'il est
sensible à ces nouvelles pauvreté il a
été très présent on le sait dans le
secteur associatif et les restos du cœur
en sont emblématiques et c'est une
manière de montrer que il doit y avoir
dans une France comme celle des années
80 de la solidarité de l'entraide et
aussi de la réciprocité et ça c'est
quelque chose aussi qu'il faut porter au
crédit de Jean-Jacques Goldman et en
tout cas ça explique sa popularité
d'aujourd'hui alors on va se poser la
question de l'engagement politique des
artistes et plus particulièrement des
joueurs donnera la parole juste après
uniquement mais vous l'aurez c'est
promis je tiens en général mes promesses
ici Mathieu encore des chanteurs de
gauche ou de droite oui oui mais ils
sont moins nombreux à le dire et encore
moins à s'engager il est loin le temps
des compagnons de route au sommet Jean
Ferrat et le Parti communiste même si
j'en fais à son distingués quand même de
temps en temps et sur plusieurs points
où il est loin le temps ou la gauche et
la droite aligné des comités de soutien
chacun avait les siens est-ce que vous
souvenez on repart des années 70-80
Dalida agrico traînait Barbara qui
roulait évidemment pour François
Mitterrand ou encore Renault qui lui
consacrera cette fois-ci en 1991 la
fameuse chanson tonton et puis en face
Johnny Hallyday qui pose avec un t-shirt
Giscard à barre quand même en 74 qui
fait on a tous quelque chose dans le
Jacques Chirac au meeting de Vincennes
en 88 qui est au premier rang du meeting
de Bercy de Nicolas Sarkozy en 2007 il
n'a jamais caché son en à droite tout
comme Michel Sardou et quelques autres
ce temps là il paraît aujourd'hui révolu
à titre de comparaison ils ont été très
très rares des chanteurs chanteuses à
prendre position dans cette campagne
présidentielle enfin dans la dernière en
2022 et une très grande tribune qui a
été signée par des artistes mais c'était
le 22 avril juste avant le second tour
où là c'était des gens qui font voter
Emmanuel Macron mais pas par adhésion
Emmanuel Macron mais sinon j'ai retrouvé
quoi princesse Erica dans un collectif
d'artistes pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon et
puis arsenic qui est venu chanter dans
un meeting de Yannick Jadot mais voilà
c'est à peu près tout qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé il y a une bascule en fait
qui date de 2007 cette année-là là c'est
vraiment les l'année des blockbusters
Ségolène Royal et Nicolas Sarkozy ce
livre un duel sans merci et pour le coup
c'est le dernier scrutin ou les
chanteurs prennent fait écho sur des
candidats en masse de la campagne au
stade qui s'achever au stade charlétisme
Royal c'était Georges Moustaki Yannick
Noah Cali Benabar les Têtes Raides
Michel Delpech Akhenaton Kerry James et
même Lenny Escudero qui était apparu
pour cette occasion et on fasse Nicolas
Sarkozy lui avait dégainé une
compilation des plus éclectiques Henri
Salvador Johnny Hallyday Mireille
Mathieu Doc Gynéco Gilbert Montagné
Carlos rikazaï Miss Dominique une
éphémère chanteuse M6 Enrico Macias donc
beaucoup d'ailleurs d'entre eux Faudel
donc beaucoup d'ailleurs sont venus
chanter le soir de sa victoire place de
la Concorde et plusieurs d'entre eux ont
beaucoup regretté l'engagement
Royal ça coûtait cher ma carrière
beaucoup de gens me reprocher ou que ce
soit Faudel tous ceux qui ont chanté à
la Concorde ont vu leur carrière
mais comme Yannick Noah 5 ans plus tard
après Le Bourget voilà après avoir
chanté pour François Hollande donc ça
marche des ça marche des deux côtés
cette espèce de censure à l'engagement
voilà donc c'est pas une bonne affaire
ni pour les arts parce que c'est piéger
pour tout le monde on vient de le dire
les artistes qui prennent le risque de
se priver d'une partie de leur public en
parlant politique regardez encore cet
été on en a parlé enfin que ce soit le
rétropédalage d'Izia sur qui s'en était
pris Emmanuel que vous les transformez
en pinata vous souvenez dans 25 concerts
ou que ce soit le débat qu'on a eu sur
la chanson de droite les lacs du
Connemara lancée par Juliette Armanet
c'est trop risqué aujourd'hui pour un
artiste qui veut vendre qui se veut mais
une stream et puis ces piégé aussi pour
les politiques qui se retrouvent à
assumer parfois un soutien qui est
devenu encombrant je pense à Valérie
Pécresse assumant le soutien de Maître
Gims maintenant qui disait pas bonne
année c'est des trucs de de chrétiens
c'est pas pour nous ça c'était en pleine
campagne présidentielle ou plus
récemment puisqu'on parle de de musique
la présence du rappeur made in
à l'université d'été d'Europe Écologie
ouvert qui a mis pour le coup les écolos
dans un bar merci beaucoup Mathieu pour
pour toutes ces explications ils venge à
Blanca vous parler de goldmanisme
courant culturel et politique c'est quoi
la gauche pragmatique si je résume
simplement alors ça c'est sûr qu'il y a
une forme de d'adhésion aux idéaux de la
gauche libérale la deuxième gauche
énergie de la société civile croyance
dans ce que j'appellerai les utopies du
quotidien typiquement les Restos du
Coeur par différence avec les utopies
millénaristes qui ont ensanglanté le 20e
siècle et qu'un carnet à certains égards
le demi-frère de Jean-Jacques Goldman
pierre et il y a aussi j'ajouterai
l'universalisme minoritaire
l'universalisme minoritaire c'est l'idée
que les minorités peuvent faire front
commun n'ont pas pour défier ou
contester la majorité mais au contraire
pour l'enrichir pour la féconder et
Jean-Jacques Goldman qui a toujours
assumé sa judéité c'est associé à
d'autres minoritaires une chanteuse
afro-américaine ou un immigré Gallois ou
des émigrés Sud vietnamiens au début de
sa carrière et cette universalisme
minoritaire vise à
partager les différences comme il l'a
dit alors aujourd'hui qu'on reste-t-il
c'est une autre question mais je crois
qu'il y a une pensée très profonde de de
la place des minorités dans l'État
national voulait intervenir tout à
l'heure parler plutôt du du Front
national de l'époque et de la chanson de
Goldman c'était peut-être pas là dessus
mais c'était sur la question de
l'immigration qui revient là maintenant
et en tant qu'historien et historien de
la chanson par exemple on peut remarquer
que quand même beaucoup de nos chanteurs
les plus fondamentaux les plus célèbres
sont des immigrés ou des fils d'immigrés
et je veux dire que dans dans vous dites
que Goldman fait œuvre
affirme cela mais je veux dire bon vous
avez Salvador Aznavour enfin je sais pas
j'ai pas tout le Moustaki je sais pas
qui on fait des chansons auparavant bien
avant Goldman un pionnier
belge même
presque Monégasques
vous voyez le dans ce mouvement qui est
très ancien qui donc effectivement Edith
Piaf cabine enfin je veux dire une
grand-mère donc ce le mouvement
migratoire ou le les semences et les
affirmations dans les chansons c'était
dans les années 80 vous avez énormément
de gens même Balavoine qui font des
chansons engagées comme comme lui et
puis
sauf que Balavoine ils l'ouvre plus que
Goldman oui bah d'une certaine manière
effectivement et physiquement en quoi
ces contradictoires ça veut dire je veux
dire qu'il faut le rappeler en tant que
historien vous devez rappeler que cette
histoire de la chanson française elle
est elle s'est faite bien avant Goldman
et avec les mêmes ingrédients que vous
voulez
évidemment vous avez tout à fait raison
mais enfin je le dis dans mon livre il
est évident que la chanson française a
été enrichie par des courants
migratoires exiliques diasporique qui se
retrouvent dans des grands chefs de la
de la variété ou de la ou de la chanson
ou de la chanson dite à texte mais il me
semble que Jean-Jacques Goldman qui a
été souvent décrit comme quelqu'un d'un
petit peu mou lisse un peu gendre idéal
il faut rappeler que justement il a
participé de ces engagements alors
certes il n'était pas encarté mais il
portait des idéaux et il est important
de les rappeler est-ce que c'est aussi
un symptôme ou un symbole de la
dépolitisation Jean-Jacques Goldman ah
non on peut pas dire ça la
dépolitisation on l'a rappelé elle vient
à partir à peu près de 2007
non au contraire je suis d'accord que
ces chansons sont des chansons qui sont
politisées non pas dans le sens de la
politique partisane ou de l'idéologie
mais simplement de par ce qu'elle
raconte alors déjà Jean-Jacques Goldman
je pense que ce qui fait son équilibre
qui le rend aussi populaire c'est le
fait que il ait pas le seul bien sûr
mais la musique américaine et les
systèmes de la musique américaine sur
lesquels il met des paroles en français
et d'une certaine façon je pense que ce
qui touche le plus le public chez
Jean-Jacques Goldman ce sont ces textes
mais si ils réussissent à toucher c'est
parce qu'ils sont portés par ces
musiques
américaines et qu'il a réussi à
comprendre les systèmes de
fonctionnement américain et qu'en plus
il arrive à chanter haut comme le font
les Anglais les Américains ce qui est
pas donné à tous les Français en dehors
de Balavoine et Francis Cabrel et
quelques autres Jean-Jacques Goldman qui
a défendu la cause des femmes on va
avoir des images d'une manifestation à
Marseille en étant 2004 c'est la journée
internationale de contre les violences
faites aux femmes à l'appel de
l'association Ni Putnik soumise regardez
on va entendre Jean-Jacques Goldman
devant ce meurtre il y a pas de société
paisible sans femme
respectée ils vengeable ça c'est un
thème récurrent des chansons de Goldman
oui absolument je pense que il incarne
d'un côté une masculinité fragile
vulnérable et de l'autre il a toujours
été en quelque sorte l'Allier des femmes
et tout particulièrement des
adolescentes qui composaient une grande
partie de son public d'où le mépris
entre snobisme et misogyny qui
ensevelissait Goldman dans les années 80
et qui était assez caractéristique de la
presse intellectuelle de gauche de
l'époque et pour revenir à cette aspect
très intéressant on est 30 ans avant
MiTo et Jean-Jacques Goldman ce se
montre se manifeste comme un allié des
femmes on le voit par exemple dans une
chanson comme doux ou comme elle a fait
un bébé toute seule qui sont presque
proto féministes et en tout cas qui
tranche avec certaines galéjas de
misogynes qu'on trouve dans un tube de
oh non je pense que c'est une forme
musicale comme le disait Yves
c'est-à-dire que la femme musicale qu'il
avait trouvé à l'époque et qui faisait
son succès était celle que que il vient
d'écrire
j'ai abordé ça parce que j'aurais bien
sûr la question de
cette de ce nouvel homme tel qu'on
l'appelait dans les années 70 c'est que
bien avant lui Michel Berger Alain
Souchon était passé par là Goldman ça
n'enlève rien c'est qualité mais c'est
pas lui qui a été le porteur dans la
chanson française de ce message là il en
a été l'héritier d'ailleurs il admirait
énormément Michel Berger et je dois dire
qu'en vous lisant vous avez un peu
tendance à attribuer à Jean-Jacques
Goldman des choses qui appartiennent à
d'autres et notamment à Michel Berger
qui est passé un mot de réponse ensuite
on parle on parle de je vous renvoie à
mon livre et je le dis dans un de ces
livres bah vous auriez vous auriez bien
sûr que dans le livre j'explique à quel
point Jean-Jacques Goldman a été
influencé par Michel Berger à qui il a
rendu hommage toute sa vie donc
évidemment il y a des points de contact
entre la chance ce qu'on appelle la
nouvelle chanson française des années 70
et le son Goldman des années 80 et
Michel Berger fait la transition de
manière évidente alors on va terminer
comme promis et revenir aux questions de
de familles politiques de ces deux
gauches dont on parlait puisque la
famille Goldman est au cœur de
l'actualité avec ce film sorti ce
mercredi consacré à Pierre Goldman
demi-frère est né de Jean-Jacques
militant d'extrême gauche condamné puis
à quitté pour un double meurtre c'est
justement le second procès que raconte
le film de Cédric Kahn on regarde un
extrait tout de suite
non mais si toutes les personnes que
vous avez citées ici ont dit du mal de
moi aux policiers c'est exactement pour
les mêmes raisons que Christiane je
ferai remarquer à la course ils sont
tous noirs et que c'est pour cette
raison et cette raison seulement qu'ils
ont tous été malmenés intimidés par les
policiers dès leur arrivée à la PJ
[Applaudissements]
Goldman sous entendez vous que la police
de ce pays est raciste non seulement je
le sous-entends mais je l'affirme et
bien c'est une eau
s'il vous plaît
nous sommes le président monsieur le
Président je pense que ce que mon client
a voulu dire c'est que certains
policiers peuvent parfois avoir un
comportement raciste certainement pas
que le corps policier dans son ensemble
est raciste non non je veux dire que la
pollycér raciste absolument toute la
police
[Applaudissements]
on est dans les années 70 mais ça ça
résonne à nos années 2023 Samia de chiro
bonsoir qui était Pierre Goldman
frère de Jean-Jacques Goldman ils
avaient le même père un juif polonais
militant communiste résistant pour la
deuxième guerre mondiale mais c'est de
fils n'ont pas du tout suivi la même
voix alors que Jean-Jacques devient un
célèbre pour sa musique Pierre lui est
un militant d'extrême gauche qui a
voyagé en Amérique du Sud où il s'est
frotté au guérilla révolutionnaire et
c'est en 1970 que les Français le
découvrent à l'occasion de ce premier
procès il est alors accusé du double
meurtre de deux pharmaciennes lors du
braquage dans une pharmacie parisienne
donc l'année précédente il est arrêté
sur dénonciation il reconnaît trois
autres braquages mais pas celui de la
pharmacie son premier procès s'ouvre
donc en 1974 et il est condamné à la
réclusion à perpétuité et il va
continuer de clamer son innocence oui et
une partie de l'opinion publique a
d'ailleurs le sentiment que de l'enquête
sur ce double meurtre aurait été biaisé
il y a des incohérences que le doute
n'aurait pas profité à l'accusé Pierre
Goldman l'année suivante saga
condamnation est cassée par la Cour de
cassation sur un motif qui n'a rien à
voir avec ce que je viens d'évoquer en
fait le PV du procès n'a pas été signé
donc un nouveau procès est organisé en
1976 et c'est sur cet épisode là que le
film dont on a vu un extrait porte le
film Le procès Goldman et alors désolé
en pour ceux qui on le voit je vous
dévoile un petit peu la fin mais qui en
fait est déjà connu c'est qu'en fait
Pierre Goldman est finalement acquitté
lors de ce deuxième procès il va pas
profiter longtemps de cette liberté
puisqu'il meurt trois ans plus tard oui
en 1979 Pierre Goldman est assassiné en
pleine rue dans le 13e arrondissement de
Paris deux hommes lui tirent dessus
avant de s'enfuir un meurtre dont on n'a
jamais retrouvé les coupables et
d'ailleurs l'affaire du double meurtre
du braquage de la pharmacie dont était
accusés Pierre Goldman n'a jamais été
résolu non plus Pierre Goldman meurt
donc à 35 ans plusieurs des milliers de
personnes vont assister à son
enterrement dans la foule on voit des
visages très connus comme Jean-Paul
Sartre Simone de Beauvoir ou encore Yves
Montand et j'en passe alors s'il n'était
pas aussi aduler par les Français que
son demi-frère Jean-Jacques Pierre
Goldman était tout de même devenu un
symbole pour l'extrême gauche françaises
le moins qu'on puisse dire Thomas en
tout cas c'est que les demi-frères ont
pris des chemins très différents
effectivement très différents merci
beaucoup Samia ivanjablanca qu'est-ce
qu'on peut dire de la relation entre
Jean-Jacques et son frère aîné Pierre
quand celui-ci est accusé du doubleur
qui garde le contact il vient le il
vient le voir en prison comment ça se
passe bon d'abord les deux frères ont
vécu en quelques années ensemble puisque
ils ont grandi dans la même fratrie vous
avez dit partager en effet non seulement
le même père mais le même patronyme donc
ils ont vécu ensemble à Montrouge
plusieurs années et il y a des il y a
des relations par exemple moi j'ai eu
accès au dossier d'instruction de Pierre
Goldman et on voit que il y a une lettre
de Pierre Goldman adressée à sa
demi-sœur où il parle de Jean-Jacques il
lui dit Jean-Jacques que la musique on
voit qu'ils discute musique et d'une
certaine manière ils avaient pas les
mêmes goûts musicaux mais ils avaient la
même passion des musiques et d'une
certaine manière ils pouvaient donc
polémiquer amicalement autour de ça et
on sait que Jean-Jacques a rendu visite
à Pierre en prison mais le parallèle
s'arrête là parce que pour le reste il
n'y a que des différences la première
différence la plus béante elle est
politique vous avez d'un côté un
gauchiste de choc qui a été d'abord dans
des services d'ordre de groupuscules Mao
ou trots dans les années 60 qui a
ensuite défrayé la chronique judiciaire
et de l'autre côté vous avez
Jean-Jacques qui est un dessin bol de la
gauche apaisé dans sa version sociale
démocrate on est avec eux en étant
duplex pardon avec l'historien Benjamin
Stora qui publie l'arrivée aux éditions
Talandier qui c'est votre parcours mais
c'est aussi ces années-là que vous
racontez dans ce livre l'arrivée qui
vient de sortir il y a 44 ans Benjamin
storage jour pour jour ça vient en
parler 15000 personnes assistées aux
obsèques de aux obsèques de Pierre
Goldman on peut rajouter au grand nom
qu'elle a cité Simone Signoret
Costa-Gavras vous y étiez Benjamin saura
pourquoi vous étiez là
oui bonsoir bien sûr j'étais là parce
que
Pierre Goldman c'était une très grande
figure de l'extrême gauche bien entendu
depuis des années 60 et puis la fin de
la guerre d'Algérie avec le front unique
et antifasciste puisque j'ai déjà le
coup de poing en car sur la table dans
les services d'ordre et quand je suis
rentré en politique après 68 son nom
était déjà connu il était il était un
personnage un personnage important bon
qui était dans la radicalité en fait et
Pierre Goldman en synthétisé aussi
quelque part
la bataille à la fois contre le fascisme
et contre l'antisémitisme qui faisait la
synthèse entre ces deux batailles
c'est-à-dire qu'il était par sa
radicalité à la croisée des chemins
entre combat contre le fascisme les
combats contre l'antisémitisme donc
c'est pour ça qu'il était naturellement
connu quelqu'un comme moi qui était
jeune à l'époque et qui était très
engagé dans le mouvement entre ce qui
c'est qu'il avait fréquenté lui-même
d'ailleurs ces mouvements là il avait
été proche du service d'ordre de
l'affaire la Fédération des étudiants
révolutionnaires simplement s'en séparer
et puis surtout surtout Pierre Goldman
il incarné aussi toute la discussion
tout le débat qui avait à l'extrême
gauche à l'époque sur le passage à la
lutte armée c'est-à-dire la question du
passage ce qu'on appellera plus tard le
terrorisme il y a une vraie débat qui a
fracturé l'extrême gauche français dans
cette époque là qui venait d'Amérique
latine c'était la question des fois des
focus mais c'était la bataille du
guérilla du guéririsme du gevarisme et
disons que moi par exemple j'appartenais
pas à ce courant qui était partisan du
guévarisme et de la lutte armée je
voudrais pardon de vous interrompre
Benjamin storage essaye de reprendre la
maps il nous reste assez peu de temps
ensuite désolé de vous interrompre c'est
toujours plus compliqué quand on est en
duplex comme ça mais je voudrais parler
de ce second process que raconte le film
peut-être d'ailleurs le premier aussi
mais il fait de son procès une tribune
politique est-ce qu'on peut dire ça
bien sûr mais il a toujours été un
militant révolutionnaire Pierre Goldman
cachés il suffit de dire ces livres de
voir sa vie son activité ses relations
bien sûr qu'il essaye d'en faire une
tribune politique il a été très marqué
par la Seconde Guerre mondiale bien
entendu la question de la Shoah ça c'est
sûr la guerre d'Algérie aussi c'est
évident c'est quelque chose qui qui le
marque donc il en fait bien sûr une
tribune que de propagande d'explication
de bataille de combat c'est un
combattant c'est un militant un
combattant révolutionnaire pas
simplement d'extrême gauche mais qui
intéresse une grande partie de la
jeunesse des années 70 de cette époque
là parce que son livre est un énorme
succès un souvenir obscur a été un très
grand succès librairie et beaucoup
beaucoup de jeunes qui s'engagaient en
politique et bien ont lu ce livre
souvenir obscur d'un juge polonais né en
France et moi ce qui m'avait toujours
est très étonné si nous quand son frère
est apparu sur la scène musicale sur le
devant de la scène plus personne ne
faisait référence
au frère au fait qu'il était le frère de
Pierre Goldman alors ça ça m'a toujours
incroyablement fasciné c'est à dire de
voir comment la presse de l'époque
traité Jean-Jacques Goldman de quelqu'un
dans le fond d'assez insignifiant tu
sais un peu de la musique légère etc
sans voir absolument pas le lien qui
pouvait être établi avec son frère avec
le parcours qui avait été le celui des
années 60 des années 70 ça m'a toujours
très étonné c'est occultation cette
séparation disons entre deux histoires
alors qu'ils ont grandi ensemble ils ont
vécu ensemble je connais un peu la
famille c'est c'était quand même assez
étrange assez curieux de croire que chez
Jean-Jacques Goldman il n'y avait pas du
tout de Pierre Goldman c'est pas vrai
alors on va en débattre merci merci
benjaminoir rester avec nous Yves Bigot
ça vous fait réagir mais c'est
Jean-Jacques Goldman qui voulait surtout
ne jamais parler il a refusé toutes les
émissions qu'il invitait ou il risquait
d'être interrogé sur son frère moi je me
souviens à l'époque et à Libération donc
en plus Pierre Goldman avait travaillé
la libération pendant des années donc
vous pensez bien que nous on était au
courant de l'existence de Pierre Goldman
mais Jean-Jacques chaque fois qu'il
venait faire
une émission avec moi à Europe 1 c'était
on ne va parler que de musique et de
guitare hors de question de parler
d'autre chose sinon je ne viens pas oui
et moi et moi qui travaillait au monde
un support supposé méprisant par rapport
aux arts populaires ce qui était quand
même pas vrai
moi j'imaginais que si j'intervisais
Goldman il fallait que je pose la
question mais c'était pas possible donc
c'était complètement fermé c'est je suis
le meilleur chanteur populaire de la
terre et je vais parler de mes chansons
et ça ça va pas quand on travaille dans
un journal généraliste qui est pas
forcément l'élite de gauche comme vous
le dites je veux dire ben c'est pas
recevable même Françoise Hardy avait des
commentaires politiques à faire sur la
libération
est-ce que c'est parce que aussi c'était
une blessure familiale que il refaisait
d'en parler c'est une blessure familial
évidente Pierre Goldman a été assassiné
en pleine rue comme un comme un comme un
chien comme un juif dans un ghetto donc
évidemment que c'est une c'est une
blessure mais je suis parfaitement
d'accord avec ce que disait
ivigo il y avait aussi une évidence gêne
de la part de Jean-Jacques et de sa
famille d'évoquer ce cette histoire et
je crois que ça renvoie aussi au modèle
d'intégration le modèle d'intégration
auquel répond Jean-Jacques et une partie
de sa famille c'est ce que j'appellerai
une discrétion Franco juive républicaine
avec un amour inconditionnel de la
France une forme de discrétion qu'on
retrouve dans certaines chansons de
Jean-Jacques Goldman qui mélange
minorité majorité avec toujours une
forme de discrétion et de pudeur et donc
le frère le frère aîné vient fracasser
cette stratégie d'intégration imaginez
des braves commerçants qui ont un
magasin à Montrouge et qui sont en fait
les parents de quelqu'un qu'on juge aux
assises bien sûr
quand vous voyez dans le film de de de
le film sur le passé
il est là Jean-Jacques il est tout jeune
etc il est il assiste au procès et on
voit bien il est dans la salle il est
dans la salle et avec son frère il a un
frère qui est important c'est très
important dans sa carrière et donc et
donc ils sont là la famille est là et on
voit comment il est effaré d'une
certaine manière par ce procès très
violent qui est fait à son frère sans
doute avec raison ou pas mais c'est
d'une violence extrême quoi c'est-à-dire
le réquisitoire et la réponse de de
pierre et quand même dans un registre
quand même qui le sidère enfin je sais
pas là c'est fictionné mais je pense que
c'était ça quand même parce que là il
est collé au mur indirectement et dans
ces dans cette problématique de
effectivement de l'intégration merci
beaucoup très vite il nous reste 20
secondes à la fois je pense qui ne
partageait pas non plus ses idées
politiques et que ça n'était pas dans sa
nature non plus merci beaucoup merci à
tous c'était un débat passionnant on
aurait pu espérer
encore de longues minutes il faut dire
vos livres pour en savoir plus en tout
cas le vôtre ça c'est sûr votre Goldman
est publié au Seuil le film Le procès
Goldman qui sort ce mercredi Cédric Kahn
on vous conseille d'aller le voir
Véronique portail votre carnet de voyage
avec Bernard Lavilliers écrire sur place
alors là il va falloir attendre un peu
il paraît au mois de novembre aux
éditions de l'équateur et Benjamin Stora
que je remercie vraiment c'était
quelques minutes mais c'était
passionnant merci encore votre livre
l'arrivée et publié aux éditions
talandiers merci à tous je vous dis à
très bientôt sur le plateau de Public
Sénat belle fin de soirée notez que
demain Oriane mansini reçoit Carole
Delga la présidente socialiste de la
région
Occitanie encore une fois une belle
soirée écouter du Goldman
[Musique]